welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and it's time to jordan
peel back the layers on the new
director's ufo movie nope there's some
major twists that nobody could have
predicted as well as some big themes
that i think are definitely worth
talking about throughout this video
we're going to be going through it all
so should you go past this point if you
haven't seen it nope and that's also the
kind of wit you can expect in this video
congratulations you've picked a crap one
and without the way thank you for
clicking this let's get into nope okay
so up top we're really busy with
comic-con at the moment so i don't
really want to do a big plot recap and
instead i'd rather focus on the major
details in the film as well as what i
think the overall theme is jordan
peele's movies are always laced with
social commentary and this picture feels
like an examination of how those that
work in hollywood are treated by the
industry this is seen in several of the
characters as well as the animals that
appear throughout there's very little
respect given to them i think that at
its core the film is about respecting
the aspects of the industry that are
often looked over the first major thing
that i think we have to talk about when
discussing the movie is the reveal of
what's going on with the apparent flying
saucer though everyone thought from the
trailers that this would be an alien
spacecraft we learn that it's actually
the alien itself yes it's aliens now the
movie itself takes place roughly over
the space of about half a year and we
learn that this creature hides amongst
the clouds hunting for prey like most
beasts this monster operates based on
instinct and if it feels threatened it
will attack there are ways to survive
encounters with it which we see through
oj who tries not to make eye contact
with it you see if one keeps their head
down and doesn't look directly at it
they can survive this but obviously with
it existing in the clouds several
animals and people they just stare up at
it now often in order to survive
encounters with wild beasts people are
told to avoid eye contact at all costs
and this is very much carried over to
the monster itself where it comes from
we don't fully know but it doesn't fail
at the end of the movie and show that
it's almost like a sort of flower
jellyfish grace randolph in her review
discussed how she thinks peel was very
much trying to talk about how we know as
little about the skies as we do the
oceans and that this creature might
actually be from earth either way we
discover throughout the film that the
beast is fed horses by a character named
dupe who used to be a child star he
starred in a sitcom in the 90s called
gordy's home that centered around a
family that lived with a chimp they
treated him like another person but he
was of course an animal and in not
respecting this they ended up suffering
the chimp went wild it injured several
people and it's basically what happens
when you don't hit the thumbs up button
now the similarities between gordy and
the alien itself are very apparent and
as we touched upon earlier i believe
this is coming on hollywood itself this
is an industry that very much takes
people in chews them up and spits them
out with little care for their welfare
mental health or anything really beyond
that there's the fascinating case of
bobby driscoll who was a child star that
did a lot of work for disney including
peter pan the studio eventually severed
ties with him and he sadly became an
addict that died in his early 30s
throughout the movie we get lines
talking about how you have to show
respect to animals and it's only upon
doing this that the characters overcome
the beast it even gets named jean jacket
after a horse that emerald wasn't able
to tame and thus her finally conquering
it at the end shows how far she's come
her jeep survived the encounter and said
see a chimp but his career never
recovered however he clearly believes
because he managed to connect with the
mad monkey that he'll be able to do the
same with the alien gordy's home is
revisited throughout the movie after
being used in the opening and it's one
of the most subtle ways to convey horror
that i think i've seen from peel now as
an adult he ended up running a venue and
we discovered that he'd been feeding the
alien horses which he had bought from oj
oj and emerald run hayward's hollywood
horses and after their father was killed
by a coin that fell from the sky they've
sort of been struggling to build on his
legacy they too carry the metaphor that
hollywood doesn't really care about
those that it uses and after years of
supplying horses to the industry they're
not really needed anymore and are cast
to the side hollywood just prefers using
green screen and vfx now so anyone in
the hayward's profession or seniors are
needed they've given up so much as well
and the father played by keith david
ended up destroying his relationship
with his daughter to work on the
scorpion king which yet might not have
been worth it in retrospect now his
death very much hangs over the pair and
they even kept the nickel that ended up
killing him though it's labeled as a
freak accident the pair believed that a
ufo was responsible for it and we
learned that it very much poops out
inanimate objects which yeah put number
two and two together with that one
now it's unable to digest things like
keys coins and chains and much like how
hollywood eats people up and then [ __ ]
them out it does too the alien rips
apart a show that jubas put together
called jupiter's claim and it kills
those in attendance including his
co-star who too was attacked by the
chimp turns out some animals just aren't
meant to be tamed and it's a powerful
lesson once more and respect and the
haywards also very much see the alien as
a way to make money and they want to use
it to propel them to the heights of
stardom like jumping up and down on the
couch on oprah this causes several
issues and to me they very much resemble
characters like tube and the
movie-making industry rather than
treating the creature with respect they
just want to use it as a commodity to
propel themselves forward and it's very
interesting commentary on how the entire
business works it's a business after all
but the alien itself has some mechanisms
to stop itself from being photographed
we discover that it causes electrical
issues likely due to a magnetic field
that surrounds it i don't want to get
too much into bro science but in order
for the thing to move the way it does it
would likely be able to manipulate its
intrinsic field or at the very least the
electromagnetics around it therefore it
shorts out anything that uses
electricity meaning that capturing an
image or footage of it is extremely
difficult thus they end up working
alongside a cinematographer named antler
who rigs up a mechanical camera he also
plays wacky inflatable arm flailing tube
men wacky waving inflatable arm flailing
too man wacky waving inflatable arm
failing too man about the ranch so that
they can see when it's close now oj uses
his horse lucky as bait in order to try
and get jean jacket to eat some bunting
which will hopefully kill it however
things go wrong with a tmz reporter
showing up looking for answers over what
happened at jupiter's claim after the
alien attacks oj emerald their friend
angel and antler have to work together
to take it down now the ladder gets
eaten along with his camera but i do
kind of have the feeling that this might
survive all the coins and stuff like
that end up coming out intact and
therefore it is possible that the camera
does too either way he sacrifices
himself to get the perfect shot and this
character very much symbolizes being
willing to die for one's art i'd like to
think that it wasn't in vain and that
his work will be found which will live
on long after him angel also barely
survives the encounter as well but he
manages to do it by wrapping himself in
barbed wire o.j seemingly sacrifices
himself in the end and emerald manages
to kill the alien using the giant tube
balloon which blows it up after it eats
it she also manages to get a photo of it
by using the camera at the bottom of a
well there now there are two big
questions that you'll likely have at the
end of the movie will people believe her
and is oj alive well firstly due to the
witnesses that arrived there at the end
i do believe that she'll be believed
these news crews definitely saw some of
what was going on and though they might
not have captured it due to their own
devices malfunctioning it is possible
that they'll still tell her story as for
oj we see that he has survived the
encounter as he arrives unlucky however
it is possible that this is just
division which is backed up by the sign
that says out hyundai this could be
hinting that he's now gone beyond this
mortal coil and that is spirit is now
looking over emerald who has learned how
to handle things herself throughout the
film we saw how her brother and father
very much had to take control of most of
the situations but her doing this show
she's finally gained her own strength
and independence though i'd like to
think he's still alive that's definitely
an interesting take and obviously let me
know your thoughts below on it now we
are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be with the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
video on screen right now that's just
for you we've selected the best for
viewers so the the algorithm guards have
now put one on screen that they think
it's right up your street you better go
prove them right as well and i'll see
you over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul have a great
weekend take care yourself peace